uh let's talk about chicago hip-hop who  would you put  on the mount rushmore of chicago rap  that's four people we gotta put four  people i gotta put myself though no you  gotta excluding yourself i exclude  myself okay  we're gonna put  chief keef okay  we're gonna put  juice mirror  chance the rapper  and dirk  no kanye  kanye cool but i can't put kanye up  there you put connie over here like  that's that's that's where you put  chance over kanye yeah like chance  i feel like it's our era kanye that's  fair you know what i'm saying  that's fair kanye west that's y'all  errol my mom and daddy know you ain't  going to catch me riding through the  city off no yeah that's very good a lot  but i [ __ ] with your music i [ __ ] with  you as a person we both geminized the  most [ __ ] like you know saying but like  why